المزيد حول ذلك يوسف زين دائما من فريق
شاهد كان منورنا ويستمر يوسف ابرز الاعمال
التي خطفت اهتمام قلوب المشاهدين
اعمال كثير متنوعه خلينا نبدا على السريع
بمنطقه المملكه العربيه السعوديه دول
الخليج مسلسل من شارع الهرم الى كان محتل
المركز الاول
كنسب مشاهده طبعا شفناه في رمضان 20 22 في
المركز الثاني كان موجود عندنا
المسلسل اللي خطف قلوب الكبير من العالم
باقي اربع حلقات يا جماعه وراح نعرف
النهايه واخيرا كمان عنا من الاعمال اللي
كانت موجوده مسلسل الميراث اللي من 2020
وهو محافظ على حاله بالمراكز الاولى وكمان
في دول الخليج كان عندنا بال المركز
الثالث انتقام مشروع هل عمل كمان اللي كنا
عم نشوف الاخوين كيف قصص الحب
بمصر المداح اسطوره الوادي
لحماده هلال كان من الاعمال ايضا برمضان
لقد نسب مشاهده جدا عاليه اللعبه
وباجزاء كامل كان دائما يكون بالمراكز
الاولى والجزء الرابع قريبا نوعدكم فيه
وايضا بالمركز الثالث كان عنا وسط البلد
وهو صوب اوبرا مصري من المسلسلات الدراميه
الطويله بنقدر نحكي كمان كان حافظ على
نفسه بالمراكز الاولى من اول ما بدا عرضها
في بلاد الشام والعراق من اكثر المشاهده
في بلاد الشام والعراق طبعا كان في المركز
الاول ها العمل اللي يعزمها يعني انه كان
فعلا جامع كثير من الابطال حيره هالمسلسل
العراقي كمان صوب اوبرا مسلسلات طويله
المستمر ايضا معانا وايضا كمان همم معنا
مسلسل
الحفره التركي اجزاؤه الاربعه بالكامل
موجوده على منصف شاهد
تنوع زي ما شفته في الاعمال
اذا بدنا نحكي عن اهم اعمال 20 23 مره
بعمل جدا ضخم وهو دكه العبيد من اعمال
شاهد الاصليه
الرائعه هبه مشاري حماده انا بحب كل
الكتاباتها من الاعمال للكل بينتظرها عم
نحكي نحن عن قصص مختلفه خمس قصص مختلفه
ولكن تمر بتزاوي هنحكي عنه اكيد بتفاصيل
اكثر بالاسبانيه
يختلف ذلك طبعا شوفي انت كل منطقه له طبعا
التي
المسلسلات الحب يحضروها ومن فتره لفتره
باحب احكي لك يعني النسب بتختلف يعني احنا
كل فتره عم نشوف مسلسله طالع المسلسلات
اللي نزلت على شهر 11 12 تدخل بالسبا لانه
لسه هلا نازله ولكن اكيد لها نسب مشاهده
جدا جدا عاليه احنا عم نحكي على مسلسلات
كانت باديه من اول السنه معنا فلقت نسب
مشاهده او عدد مشاهدات اعلى احنا بنشكرك
جزيل الشكر يوسف زين الدين نخطب معك اخر
حلقه في اخر دقيقه في صباح العربيه لهذا
اليوم